- You brought pizza?
- Yeah well, apparently
great minds think alike.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Because I also brought
my favorite New York pizza.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- It's from Francesco's which
is my neighborhood spot.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- It's got a beautiful
blend of thin and thick.
It's a gorgeous cheese.
(laughing)
(audience laughing)
- Okay, I love this you
have promo and everything.
Here's the thing I need to taste test.
- Of course.
- Yep, yep.
- Get in there.
- Here's the thing I'm gonna get in here.
I'm going to taste let's
see which one's better.
Yours or Amber's.
(gasp)
(Kelly mumbles)
- I was trying to do it lady like.
(laughing)
(audience laughing)
- Oh my God pizza you're so good!
(audience cheering)
- Give it up for pizza.
(applauding)
- Not only did you originate
the title role on Broadway,
but you also won to Tony, Emmy and Grammy
for your performance.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] So, I have a question?
I don't know that this has ever been done.
But like if you win
like an Oscar for this,
which is possible.
Like has anyone ever achieved
Egot status with one role?
- I actually don't know
the answer to that but.
- I mean if it I mean you need like,
there needs to be like a
special award for that.
(giggling)
- [Kelly] That's amazing.